[Música]
entre 2016 e 2019
eu tive o privilégio de passar uma
jornada incrível aqui no norte de minas
foi pela instituição que eu trabalhei
anteriormente e ela fomenta muito
empreendedorismo e eu mergulhei de corpo
e alma nessa jornada
nesta terra tão boa tão gostosa de
pessoas que fazem acontecer e eu vou
falar agora tem muito a ver com a
história dessas pessoas e com a minha
também porque eu consegui entrar no
mundo delas no universo delas gerou uma
empatia profunda entre eu e estes
empreendedores e situações também bom o
que aprendi sobre empreendedorismo no
norte de minas
o sertão mineiro esse ser é de ser
humano e tão é de empreendedorismo mesmo
tão batalhador tão lutador que tira
leite de pedra numa região onde chove
pouco ou quase não chove
e eles conseguem aprender desaprender
prestar atenção usar saberes e fazeres
para se sustentar
para fomentar a economia local essas
pessoas
o com elas o movimento é diferente o
sertão também faz menção aos poetas e
que buscaram inspiração aqui no norte de
minas e nordeste do brasil são eles
afonso arinos euclides da cunha
graciliano ramos guimarães rosa e um
memorável darcy ribeiro então eu faço
uma menção a eles que com ele
encontraram inspiração no norte de minas
para os seus contos e conseguiram
amarrar de uma forma tão ímpar a vida do
sertanejo norte mineiro características
do comportamento empreendedor da vítima
e clean fez um estudo sobre o que estes
empreendedores têm e que os fazem
diferente então ele chegou à conclusão
que dez características eles tinham em
comum e essas características fazem
diferença na vida deles e das pessoas
que habitam em seu círculo e ele disse
também que existe dois tipos de
empreendedores os que fazem acontecer e
os que esperam acontecer os que lideram
a mudança e aqueles que se vitimizam
então dentro desta dinâmica ele chegou a
esta conclusão aqui três blocos de
premissas que são a realização o
planejamento e o poder
estas estes são os comportamentos que
estes empreendedores têm em comum que os
diferenciam da manada
são pessoas que têm uma pegada diferente
ela tirou leite de pedra elas não
esperam o futuro acontecer
pelo contrário elas constroem o próprio
futuro
mesmo sabendo que ele é incerto pois bem
e dentro dessa perspectiva nós vamos
falar que o primeiro comportamento que é
a busca de oportunidade
a pessoa que tem esse comportamento ela
não se acomoda pra ela não tem idade
ela utiliza a experiência do passado a
vivência do presente para construir seu
futuro não tem idade seja novo seja na
idade madura essas pessoas têm algo
diferente e durante a minha jornada eu
conheci esta personagem aqui ela
chama-se neiva
a senhora neiva mora na cidade de
mirabela
uma pessoa simples humilde mas ela viu
uma oportunidade naquela cidade
montar uma pousada aconchegante com o
café da manhã é com um bom atendimento e
tornar aquele espaço o tanto quanto mais
humano pra quem passa pela rodovia para
quem viaja e eu tive o privilégio de
conhecer a neiva uma pessoa tudo tempo
sorridente cheia de contos e causos
quantas noites e viajando pela empresa
anterior
eu sentei na varanda da casa dela
somente para o vila e eu te convido a
ouvir as pessoas que têm essa bagagem
elas têm muito a nos ensinar
elas não têm muitas vezes títulos
acadêmicos mas ela tem muito chão pisado
então é essa experiência que eu trago
para vocês da neiva assuma riscos e
responder por eles
esta característica é daquele
empreendedor das pessoas que calculam
milimetricamente os passos que elas vão
dar e elas pulam na escuridão elas pulam
no bandejão anp porque elas querem
vivenciar um novo elas querem quebrar
protocolos sair da rotina e dentro desta
dinâmica eu conheci estas mãos
habilidosas
o actor
muito bem era um sábado de manhã e eu
fui ao mercado municipal de montes
claros e tive contato com esta
personagem que cortava habilidosamente
este couve e eu vi eu percebi que ele
chama muita atenção eu gravei vários
vídeos pra poder decifrar o que ela
pensava depois eu troquei uma idéia com
ela e ela disse eu treino muito porque
eu sei que esse corte é artesanal e eu
quero que meu cliente entenda que esse
produto vem da roça ele tem sabor único
e eu quem faço eu não coloco uma máquina
para fazer então esta é a lição que eu
trago desta empreendedora que coloca o
coração naquilo que faz
eu aprendi bastante naquela manhã de
sábado na busca pelo padrão e pela
excelência os empreendedores
eles investem bastante naquilo que eles
acreditam que não vá somente beneficiá
lo mas que vai modificar a expectativa
ea visão dos seus clientes
em uma das minhas empreitadas e passei
uma semana neste lugar aqui
essa daqui apresenta somente uma das
pousadas do vale do peruaçu te convida a
conhecer um pouco daquela cultura e dos
saberes dos fazeres o tanto que as
pessoas se dedicam o tanto que elas
fazem com primou com zelo com amor
o café da manhã arruma o quarto do
hóspede e faz com que aquela jornada
seja melhor possível para você aqui eles
fazem o melhor utilizando ingredientes
caseiros fresquinhos que desafiam
qualquer paladar
então lá no pelo aço eu vi de perto a
qualidade muito lindo trabalho que
aqueles empreendedores fazem esta que
apenas uma das várias pousadas que lá
também tem esse padrão persistência pois
bem esta é uma característica de quem
acorda cedo e dormir tarde
geralmente são pessoas que não se
acomodam não se vitimizam elas caem mas
elas levantam e eu tive o privilégio de
conviver com pessoas com esta
característica e cada persona que
apresentada eu gostaria que vocês civis
em nelas porque elas moram ou aprenderam
nesta região com estes povos povos que
trazem no seu cabedal de conhecimento
muitas experiências muitas coisas legais
muito conhecimento e muito legado e nas
minhas empreitadas
eu tive o privilégio de conviver com
este personagem ele está aqui na platéia
este é o leandro homens olhando homens
poderia desistir na primeira dificuldade
que ele teve em sua vida este rapaz ele
acorda cedo e não tem hora pra domingo
ele vai de sol a sol levando um serviço
diferenciado troca de óleo onde as
pessoas tinham pouco tempo na cidade
ele começava a capital os clientes na
rua e deixava o escritório à sua zona de
conforto e partir para a zona de
confronto o leandro é a cara do futuro
que queremos pessoas que fazem acontecer
que caem mas levantam elas encontram na
dificuldade a oportunidade e o
aprendizado de fazer acontecer
então é essa a mensagem que este
empreendedor trouxe pra mim e com
certeza impactando a vida de muita gente
comprometimento pois bem na anterior a
gente falou de persistência o
comprometimento é característica típica
de quem se entrega de corpo e alma é de
quem faz um sacrifício pessoal muito
grande pra atingir uma causa maior e uma
das histórias muito lindas que eu
encontrei meu caminho foi de um garoto
de 9 anos chamado isaac o isaac entregou
a vida muito sofreu único homem da casa
com 19 anos o pai ele era cortador de
cana então ele viajava muito para a
região do interior de são paulo durante
vários momentos do ano e isaac tomava
conta dos seus irmãos e era um homem da
casa um garoto franzino mas determinado
cheio de força eu encontrei o isaac numa
das minhas palestras que eu fiz sobre
empreendedorismo mercado em vendas na
cidade de espinosa minas gerais
quando terminou a minha palestra no
universo de mais de 100 pessoas e
profissionais
o isaac saiu do meio da multidão e pediu
um momento meu
aquilo me chamou muita atenção ele
queria dicas de como vender mais e
melhor de como ter um negócio dele
formalizado porque ele falou que tinha
um sonho e sustentar sua família e eu
comecei a ajudar
aquilo me chamou muita atenção me tocou
eu comecei a conectar o isaac com
diversas pessoas até o isaac chegar
neste momento aqui ele realizou seu
sonho ele montou um espeto uma
inspetoria na cidade de espinosa ea
renda dele que era apenas 36 reais por
noite saltou ele mesmo revelou ele só
disse gil é mais de 34 mil por semana
ele consegue tirou a família dele de uma
situação de bastante dificuldade e
começou ajudará a estudar
oprah a mobilete que um dia ele perdeu
mas perdeu para quem ele fez foi ganhar
ele vendeu por 400 reais para poder
comprar o maquinário dele pra começar
este negócio
isaac também a casa do futuro que
queremos ele não se acomoda é um
empreendedor por necessidade e no nosso
país tem muitos
o certo seria por oportunidade mas nem
sempre é corre numa linha reta a estrada
é cheia de sinuosidades quebra molas e
radares
as coisas nem sempre são do jeito que a
gente planeja e aí cabe a cada um de nós
ir lá e fazer acontecer com os recursos
que a gente tem informações bom imagine
um local com o pão de queijo quentinho
um café fresquinho ou dois dedos de
pinga é isso mesmo eu estou me referindo
a um famoso café no centro da cidade de
montes claros onde todos os dias vários
repórteres e profissionais da
comunicação informais
eles captam informações da cidade
inteira e da região e começam a
compartilhar naquele ambiente com quem
com empresários com empreendedores com
curiosos pessoas que querem saber a
última manchete do dia seja aonde tem o
combustível mais em conta na cidade e
aquelas pessoas começam a trocar essa
informação eu estou me referindo a um
café no centro da cidade montes claros
onde as pessoas utilizam a socialização
onde elas utilizam a conexão para poder
tomar as decisões nas suas empresas
então o empreendedor ou ele capta a
informação do ambiente
depois ele faz um filtro daquilo que
realmente lhe convém para que tome as
melhores decisões planejamento planeja
bem a sua rota aqui eu coloquei uma
imagem ilustrativa de uma das viagens
que eu fiz a cidade eo pardo de minas e
quando eu cheguei nesta
cruzi ada que já na saída de montes
claros tem essa placa
e aí cabe a cada um de nós nas placas da
vida onde tem mais de um caminho a gente
decidir qual experiência a gente quer
viver
eu escolhi dependendo do meu estado de
espírito daquilo que eu queria colher
eu escolhi a melhor rota uma rota você
vai na br-251 vira à esquerda e vai pôr
janaúba e porteirinha a estrada é mais
tranquila
dá pra você ouve o mpb quem sabe a outra
estrada a25 que você vai por salinas por
taiobeiras da magistrada mais agitada
que você pode talvez escolher uma música
diferenciada o técnico por exemplo
mas o mais importante disso aqui é você
saber apreciar o caminho a jornada a tua
experiência é mais importante o que você
quer da sua vida quando você começa a
tirar a tua idéia da cabeça o
planejamento é fundamental para
empreendedores de sucesso
imaginada você planejar se você não tem
metas aqui também eu convivi com uma
pessoa extremamente profissional e que
ela utiliza muito as metas
ela ajudava a gente fazer as metas do
ano seguinte baseado no ano anterior
é um profissional fora da curva muito
observador e eu tive esse privilégio tê
lo como líder e comentou eu estou
falando do cláudio o cláudio é um
profissional diferenciado a sua sala de
portas abertas e ele dava sempre
direcionamento para mim para os meus
colegas
o cloud deixava a gente trabalhar com
liberdade passava a meta ea gente
construía elas através das nossas
capacidades
o cláudio é uma pessoa que faz acontecer
no jogo de poder nós encontramos o
network que é característica fundamental
para quem realmente quer conseguir um
resultado através das conexões humanas e
eu também tive o privilégio de conviver
com esta pessoa que chamada hebe mendes
arrependes fomenta a cultura
de durham no norte de minas ela utiliza
todos os seus contatos de forma genial
se a pessoa se sinta que está sendo
usada mas pra quê pra fazer conexões e
fazer com que tenha se mais resultados
na área de cultura empreendedora
autoconfiança olha só um pássaro quando
ele repousa em uma árvore ele não teme
que seu galho quebre porque a sua
confiança não é no galho mas nas suas
asas
os empreendedores é de passar por
diversas tribos ações mas o quanto ele
tem autoconfiança de acreditar no sonho
dele eu encontrei aqui no norte de minas
as mulheres artesãs de curral de dentro
já fica pra lá de salinas e essas
mulheres eram diferenciadas eram
mulheres que utilizavam disso daqui do
forno a forma produtos artesanais para
sustentar sua família e ter uma renda
mais essas mulheres são a cara do futuro
que queremos pessoas que não se acomodam
que realmente fazem acontecer com os
recursos que têm
mas como definir tantos saberes tantos
afazeres tanta gente boa com as quais eu
convivi e que 18 minutos eu tive que
fazer um resumo bom eu faço uma metáfora
com a mandava pra quem não conhece a
mangava é este tipo aqui de besouro ou
abelha foi estabelecido científicamente
que a mangava não pode voar lá ela tem a
cabeça grande demais e as asas pequenas
demais
segundo as leis da aerodinâmica
simplesmente não pode voar mas ninguém
disse isso à mangava e assim ela voa
estes são os empreendedores no norte de
minas